I actually do think it's important that
you're just proud of your kids for who
they are so they don't think that they
have to do X Y or Z to make you love
them to make them proud of you I think
what you and I are talking about is
actual self-esteem instead of
manipulated self-esteem the only way
you'll get self-esteem is if you know
you're actually good at something yeah
like I don't think everyone could be an
all-world Hall of Fame X but I'm sure
right now someone's an accountant who
could have been one of the really
significantly top five percent auto
mechanics you know you talk about it and
I talk about a ton of taste things
AV Audio experience
Vayner Nation I'm pretty sure what I'm
about to say is true uh the gentleman
that is joining me today is probably the
guest that has most been on my podcast
in the history of my podcast I think
this is the third time he's on my
podcast I've been on his once I don't
think I have a three-time podcast guest
uh if anyone thinks they are please
email me and I apologize but the reason
is this is one of truly my favorite
individuals that I've come across in my
almost 30 years now professional career
um I I like him I like what he stands
for I like how he goes about his
business and he's got a new book when
the team reached out and said Hey Rye
podcast what do you think I said yes and
and it's just as easy as a yes as it
comes I'm excited to know what the new
book's about I'm excited that he's in
person and not on Zoom because that's
always an extra good element and uh
that's all I got to say so Ryan holiday
how are you dude it's always good to see
you you're good the best yes of course
you decided not to age something that I
noticed when as soon as you walked in
like this [__] looks the same
every time I see him I I guess you too
though you get out of here
um but it's a dignified thank you I do
feel a little bit more significant
um speaking of significance I know that
you won't write unless you've got
something to say so let's get right into
it because we don't have a ton of time
one page a day a piece of Timeless
advice that makes you better at what's
obviously your most important job which
is being a better parent I love it so
the daily Dad yes
um
366. there's a leap day
is there yeah well of course so so the
day when the daily story came out I knew
nothing about this medium the idea of
like a one page a day book and
you know you go there's 365 days a year
but no what if you read it in a year
where there's a leap year you've got a
service that day talk to me about this
genre because I think that would fit my
content well I think I'm about to yeah
I'm about to get excited here right now
and come up with my next book dude when
when my agent suggested I do a daily
book I said why I said well because
people are interested in stoicism but
where do they start right right if I
hear about interview which of your books
should I start with it's not it's a
question you can't really answer it's
like when you're like you hear a band
which one should I start with yeah like
Greatest Hits I like that the greatest
hits and so that's what that's what the
daily thing is so Dan stoko is one quote
and then a story each day inspired by
Stone philosophy this is the parenting
version of that Facebook sold almost two
million copies now what's that the day
of stock has sold almost 2 million
copies now
crushed good for you which I never would
have expected went viral well totally
viral because there's something not just
about reading one page a day but reading
one page a day every year so books that
you can return to over and over again
are really really powerful I love that
and there there's this stoic idea that
we never step in the same river twice so
the page is the same but we're different
a hundred percent and I think it's it's
the biggest people ask me all the time
why do you feel why do you continue to
make content and I'm like because I
don't know if this is going to be the
day where even though I'm saying the
same 17 things
I'm seeing them in different contexts
I'm speaking about current events so it
might hit a different about AI or
blockchain or Tick Tock that was
different than Facebook or search engine
optimization but I know that today might
be the day and by the way I know that
because I get dozens and dozens of
emails and DMS every day saying today
was the day I've been hearing the same
[__] about patients I have no idea why
this YouTube short got me but it finally
clicked I was talking to one of your
content guys and they were like Gary
says I forget the number that they're
like Gary says X things he has like this
is the things that you do but you do
them when you're traveling different
places the question's slightly different
what's happening in the in the world is
slightly different and that's the same
idea that that same P you've been doing
this one riff for 15 years now but
because of what's happening in the world
because the the then if the algorithm uh
serves it up it suddenly resonates with
someone also because there's this great
expression when the teacher when the
student is ready the teacher so you've
been doing the same content but the
person wasn't ready to hear it and
what's been really fun for me in this
last three to four years is I've sensed
very clear self-awareness shifts as well
for example in my last book I spoke
about having a real vulnerability around
Candor so I didn't even know to talk
about Candor 10 years ago because I
hadn't gone through the Journey of the
gray hairs of recognizing whoa this is
one of my kryptonites in a world where I
have a lot of success and a lot of
happiness
oh [__] most of the things that have not
gone well for me professionally and
personally was my inability to be
candorous out of not being interested in
Conflict which threw everyone for a loop
that didn't know me because on stage in
podcasts I can be very kind of direct
and cameras but in real life when I love
someone my teammates people I love it
was hard for me because I don't want to
I always thought that it made people
scared and so I had to go through my own
Journey so that becomes a part of your
content so for everyone listening we
have our things we believe in but then
we also have our life Journey which can
add things to the repertoire my wife
said something to me the other day
that's related to that I wonder what you
think she said we're being too nice and
we don't have any room left to be kind
I think what that is is like she's
probably defining that as the nice
facade as an overreaction to the
pressures of our society being quite not
cordial we've lost civility people don't
know how to have a civil disagreement
we've got into full sixth grade mode
yeah every single 40 year old is sixth
grade now we just make fun of each other
until social media to absurd it's
devastating and I think I understand
exactly what your wife is saying it's
it's
you know what where I think she's going
is sometimes telling someone the truth
is the nicest thing you can do for them
but we're also politically correct if
we're overly affected by the meanness in
society I am so empathetic to what you
said I think she was also saying like
we're being nice to these people that we
don't know and then we're not we don't
have any room left at home with our kids
like well it's so nice and we're not but
then we're we don't have patience with
our six-year-old because we used it all
up yeah that's a call that was taking
too long I have this Theory I've been
thinking a lot about for taking the best
people in your life for granted and
working on the people so you're like
taking the people that give you energy
yeah or affirm your energy for granted
and you're spending all your time and
energy trying to fix the people in your
life that are sucking your energy out
and so it's this is a scenario where
nice guys finish last you know one of my
I'm actually gonna make a t-shirt Nice
Guys Finish First Nice Guys Finish First
is a piece of content I need to make
immediately because I'm like really
stuck on it I've always said like the
biggest [__] statement in the world
is nice guys finish last now I'm just
like [__] it I'm gonna bring it even
further nice guys finish first but in
the micro
a place where nice people finish in a
peculiar spot is when the people around
them take them for granted because
they've been so consistently good and
you know it's like one parent versus the
other one sibling versus the other one
relationship versus the other at work
you're spending so much time trying to
fix the bottom 20 instead of putting the
energy in the top 20 there's a lot of
that I was thinking about this like
think about all the nonsense we put up
with like we'll listen to someone's
boring story we'll pretend to be
interested in this or that and then our
kid wants us to wants to talk to us
about some video games and we're just
like I can't it's so like such a good
point we'll fake it with people who
don't matter and then we can't will
ourselves to be interested or to put it
in with the people who really do matter
boy do I love that
that it's taking you for granted yeah
you're taking your child for granted
versus being civil in society because
you want to stand up stability in a time
where it's not makes so much sense let's
get into the book yeah so you went a
little more so when I hear two million
copies daily stuff that can work for
everyone yeah you went with the daily
Dad yes instead of the daily parent yes
talk to me through that I decided
because I know you yeah and when I say
this everyone at home when I say I know
you I've known O'Brien for a long time
then we surrendered this serendipitally
kind of interacted at a conference that
led to a deeper relationship and I've
really gotten to know Rye because he's
you know now part of vayner's speakers
our speaking bureau we've gotten close
we've done it the best thank you you
know [__] man you're in the theater in
L.A right yeah I will never forget that
day I saw you there like we've had some
limited interactions to that point and
like every part of my Spidey senses we
were just starting Vader speakers every
part of my Spidey senses was like this
kid is like where I was like he's
destined to be so much bigger if he has
the right partner in crime we are
definitely the right partner in crime at
this time and it just watching you and
Zach build your public speaking career
has been one of the most enjoyable
little micro Parts in my business life
five years it's been huge for me I'm
very very grateful so is my family so I
know you you're [__] a marketer and
an author and you got a lot to you I
feel like I do so I can sense it you
consciously decided to make the audience
more narrow on this because I know you
debated it because I know you too well
you had to have debated it at least in
your mind even if not on paper talk to
me through that strategy yeah right
daily stoic is Broad and then obviously
there are lots of parents there's not
really any good parenting books for men
most of them are terrible they're
patronizing or they're written for women
but I did feel like look what good is it
to be successful to have a broad hit if
you can't use that credibility that
success that relationship with the
audience to do something you really care
about that you really want to do and
I've gotten better every day from
writing the daily dad email and from
writing the book and from making the
content so it's something and being in
debt and and again if you don't use your
success s to make stuff like Casey and I
said said this to me we don't make art
to make money we make money to make more
art yeah right and and I I wanted to do
it so obviously I care about the book I
know it's by the way that line that
Casey said to you is so right like Mr
Beast is living that at scale right now
like all like I've watched that whole
journey yeah talk about someone who
really lives that yes and it's just so
obvious I guess that is the money it's
why I think I'm a good entrepreneur I
want to be an entrepreneur more than
anything I just need to stay the money's
the oxygen to continue to make up [__]
yes and that's what you know that that
when I say make up [__] that's slang for
being very creative and coming up with
all sorts of different things but I
would say almost half the audience of
the daily dad is women it makes sense as
a dad I feel weird calling the daily
parent because I don't I can't speak to
the a woman or somebody else's
experience other than my own but I don't
know it's also like the daily dad had
something to it that the daily parents
366 meditations on parenting love and
raising great kids you know do when I
sign it I cross out kids and I write
adults because that was one of the best
things I ever heard someone said I'm not
raising kids I'm raising I like that
right you don't want a kid no I get it
right like I like that which one of them
most hit you
so I think when I wrote 12 and a half
yeah and I was like I'm gonna put a half
in there and talk about something I
think is massively important to be a
successful leader and I'm going to show
my vulnerability yeah so that people
feel comfortable realizing some of the
stuff that comes natural or I'm good at
that they might be vulnerable and
everybody has a half
writing that made me better I can't like
it helped me get better at Candor
because I was going through the process
knowing that you take the process even
more seriously than I do at least from
my perspective which one of these daily
meditations 366 like after you kind of
thought it through or wrote it down or
put it to bed where you like [__]
tonight as soon right now I'm walking
out of wherever I am and I'm gonna be
better at this for my kids yeah there's
a line from Seneca who says we can't
choose our parents but we can choose
whose children we want to be we can't
whose children we want to be so it
doesn't matter where you came from the
flaws of your parents the flaws of your
culture uh the flaws of generations past
you decide how it's going to be in your
family and what you're going to pass
down to them in his Broadway show
Springsteen talked about this he says we
can be an ancestor or a ghost right a
ghost haunts your kids passes on
generational traumas bad habits
weaknesses just our flaws and an
ancestor is someone that guides our kids
that inspires them that helps us work
through the past to be better in the
future and I think what I'm what I think
we're all trying to do is give the good
stuff that we got from our parents to
our kids but also give them what we
didn't get what we needed when we were
10 and we were an awkward kid in glasses
or we were lonely or we were artistic or
whatever it is we're trying to give them
what we didn't get
how much this just gets me to a thing
that I'm spending a lot of time on
why or how much or what do you see with
the concept of victim
or leaning into accountability so one of
the I'm very interested in modern
parenting
it you know it's so fascinating to watch
so many parents execute exactly what
they were upset about with that their
parents did to them onto their kids
I have so many parents 30 40 50 year
olds that I've interacted with that are
are Hall of Fame at being victims my
parents my parents at 42 years old yeah
at 52 years old at 62 years old and 29
years old
it's funny that you just went to where
you went where do you sit on like the
modern world's lack of being in love
with accountability and realizing they
can control this it might be the essence
is still philosophy is the idea that we
don't control what's happened to us but
we control how we respond to what's
happened to us so
what happened to you might have been
unfair it might have been awful it might
have been unjust it might be something
that haunts you to this day but it's
still on you to decide the end of that
story where it's going right so when I
go to therapy when I read books when I
have conversations late at night with my
wife when I'm thinking about stuff
working on on stuff in my life it's
about being better and doing better it
it's not accepting that the past
dictates the future and I think that you
can you can accept and deal with and
process and articulate the things that
you went through in life but that
doesn't change the fact that here in the
present moment you've got to do
something about it and you can write the
end of that story
which do you think the Judgment of
others dictates people's inability to
like change that perspective
I mean isn't that the real problem with
parenting too is that everyone is
thinking about what the other parents
are doing and not what they think is
right or what what's important that's
everything yeah to me the keeping up
with the Joneses and the Judgment of the
Joneses is the thing I think about every
day yeah like I just I am crippled
by how many people continue to wake up
tomorrow and do a lot of things
singularly based on three to nine
people's opinions
and not their own opinion about
themselves and their wants and needs
which is why
I continue to talk about this concept of
spending time with the elderly that are
not your grandparents because you really
start to get a perspective of regret
that I think if you had that perspective
you know it changes everything I think a
lot about like I wish I knew what I knew
now like everybody's life would be
better if you're at 18 understood
everything you would feel at 38 you'd be
more patient you'd be more like you'd be
different and so I think one of the ways
to get that is to get wisdom from others
and yes I think it's the whole [__]
thing right I Know This Woman's her name
is Dolores she's 94. I call her my
grandmother and I was talking to her the
other day and she was telling me her big
regret
was that when her kids were little she
took pride in how clean her house was
and she said people used to come over
and go it doesn't look like you have
kids and that meant something to her
right and now we do this like we look at
influencers and what was her point that
she didn't let her kids have a little
room to play and get dirty her point was
how hollow that seems in retrospect of
course let him color on the walls have
fun yes
today people are going to be looking at
Instagram reels and they they get a
false version of what people's houses
look like they don't realize that just
out of frame is all the same toys that
are on the floor in your house and so
when I look at my house I want it to
look like I have kids because I do have
kids and they're a central part of my
life in existence and I don't and and so
when you talk to people who are older
who have been through it you can get
perspective there's this great
expression that um any fool can learn by
experience we want to learn from the
experience of others and talk to people
who've been through it who are on way on
the other side and you realize a lot of
the things you're valuing as a pair
parent things you're feeling guilty
about as a parent things you're
comparing yourself to against in other
parents they will not matter to you in
the end not only will they not matter
they may dictate your behavior to
something that actually creates the real
vulnerability yeah my argument is like
of course yeah think about when you're
17 what you care about grades like a
pimple on your [__] forehead like
what car the other kids got like college
like all of it at 38 you're like what
the [__] well what do you think is going
to happen with kids it's gonna be the
same game and you know I think that
the thing that I'm spending a lot of
time thinking about is like what are the
mod mod do you touch on in the book some
of the modern Dynamics I'll give you an
example
I'm really worried about eighth place
trophies because I not because I want to
be mean to kids because I think we
taught a whole generation that Merit and
the truth
is not real and then they get into the
real world and they're struggling with
because they've demonized losing I think
the concept of demonizing losing is very
very dangerous because then you're
scared of losing and life is tons of
micro losses and the quicker you can get
adapted to it I do see a very big
correlation of people as Elders being
comfortable with micro losses and I
think when you take away micro losses
like it's okay if your soccer team
sucked it's okay like and we try to do
these things to protect and then in
essence it's like you know bubble babies
and they get sick all the time right or
like zoo animals don't do well in the
wild when you let them loose
thoughts on that my oldest is doing Jiu
Jitsu right now and when he comes home I
don't ask him did he win I asked him
what he learned right what did you work
on today what did you get better at
today yeah so it's of course competition
is an important part of life and I think
uh telling people that winning doesn't
matter is wrong but also like instead of
giving an eighth place participation
trophy why don't you just focus on what
did you learn how did you grow did you
do your best these are these are
questions that allow your kid to feel
proud of themselves without making up a
reason to feel proud of themselves and
and what I also talked to him because
when he first started he was he was
reluctant to tap out right and I go it's
fine to tap out as long as you learn
something from that and then was he
willing to pass out because he sounds
like my kind of guy but but the point is
you you can't lose in like you saw uh
giannis's uh thing there's no losing in
sports right you get better to me it's a
game in progress whether it's School
entrepreneurship Sports art one of the
things I think that I'm fascinated by is
we treat it as an absolute when they're
7 9 12 when in reality a lot of like the
end game plays out later yeah and so for
me it's like are you moving the ball
down the field you know a lot of that
stuff came natural to me I remember
getting crushed by my best friend
Brandon Brandon you're gonna love this
so I crushed Brandon every baseball card
show we did like we did like 10 baseball
card shows freshman year high school
where like I'd make 700 bucks and you
make 40. and I'd make a thousand and
make a hundred and this weird show at
the Clinton I will never forget this the
Clinton Holiday Inn
off of Route 78 and somehow not only
does he crush me
but like a relative came early and he
packed up early and went to Phillipsburg
to another show to do buying because he
had already smashed it and he like beat
me he sold more stuff than me and I
remember like even at 14 being like this
is the best
like didn't need a single person of
wisdom to say like you'll learn from
this however I don't think I'm like a
Cabbage Patch Kid and came up clearly
the parenting I was getting along the
way even by 14 didn't even need my mom
or dad to reinforce that I was already
there and when I think back to where I
am in this exact second of happiness and
productivity
all of it much of it an enormous amount
of it is that yeah and I'm very
concerned that that is not a popular
framework right now in parenting and I
guess I'm curious how much or little do
you touch on that overall theme in this
book yeah I I think our job is to help
them become what they're meant to be yes
right it's not to make them what they
want to be to force them to like
something it's to find the thing it's
not to give them a participation Trophy
and something they're bad at but it's to
help them find the thing that they don't
want to be bad at because they love it
so much and they're totally committed to
it that your job is to help them
discover that thing that lights them up
to find their people right this is my
tribe this is the thing I love this is
the thing and not demonize it and not
judge it it could be how old are you I'm
35. right as a 47 year old watching how
many parents demonized Our Youth Level
like don't get into rap don't get into
you know punk rock don't get into video
games don't all I mean do you understand
that 47 how many parents were mortified
that their kids wanted to cook that was
the help yeah
meanwhile what happened on the back end
of that was the explosion of the Food
Network and famous chefs
I you already touched on it Esports
makes me laugh every day of the week all
those parents that took the Tony Hawks
because I always use Tony Hawk because
he was the skateboarder of the
generation before me that happened more
in the mid 80s
and like skateboarding I remember when I
was in second third grade exploded and
like that's not a profession Tony Hawk
video games and profession booger ninja
like it's so clear that parents I love
that you said that I I really hope we're
getting closer to not the doctor lawyer
engineer go to college or not be Roger
Federer or Shaquille O'Neal because the
Sports by the way one of the things that
concerns me is the sports parents are
now making their kids pick one sport by
third grade because they have a delusion
that they're going to be a [__]
parents every one of you that are
listening none of your kids are gonna be
pro athletes none of them promise if
you're listening right now zero and by
the way if you actually have that app
and hit us up for better sports but
like it's 99.9 and so back to your point
there's kits right now in fourth grade
that their dad is forcing them to pick a
sport even though they like playing
football basketball and baseball because
the dad's delusional and thinks that the
kid picks one right now and puts all
their efforts into that they'll be a
professional baseball player meanwhile
they're gonna have to get Tommy John
surgery by ninth grade or whatever it's
insane you you gotta you should
cultivate a range of interests and
expose them to a variety of things take
them all over the world that every
possible thing have no judgment about
and by the way when people hear us I
apologize Ryan all over the world can be
done virtually yes a lot of people like
all over the world I don't have that
you're right but with the way the
internet works now take them all over
the world get into Wikipedia get into
EBT get into YouTube and show them the
world and show them the videos and when
they find the thing that lights them up
your job is to encourage that facilitate
it give them the kinds of lessons that
allow that to be their thing what is the
pro what is the Robert Green calls this
their life's task right you have to your
job is to help your kids find their
life's task and that might be something
that makes no sense to you that might be
something that's scary to you that's
weird to you might be something your
parents the grandparents think is stupid
which is killing a lot of parents that
are listening right now literally their
mom and dad is still dictating things to
them because they're in that framework I
see that the amount of DMs I get like
Gary you know because what the things I
talk about Gary I think I agree with you
that my son should not go to college but
like my dad
is like a professor at Yale I'm like
what does that have to do with anything
well we talked about comparing yourself
to other parents when I dropped out of
college my parents took it extremely
hard because I was the first of any of
their friends kids to do such a thing
right and the funny thing is the thing
they were so alarmed about when I was a
teenager that I was spending all this
time in my room on the computer that's
what I do now that was me finding my
thing and if they had taken a little
more time to understand it and connect
with it it wouldn't have been as scary
for me to drop out of college because
they would have understood it and they
would have seen what I saw in it or what
it did while I'm on this subject matter
the biggest thing I get hit up by
parents is like hey my son's like you
let me give you the answer what my
parents did exactly with my mom and dad
did what Ryan said which is why I'm a
happy person and successful what I do
they said okay Mr bad grades this is
what they said to me at 14. now that
you've proven that you're not going to
have a life based on the ease of
Academia they didn't say this
articulately by the way they said you
will now work yeah and a lot like cool
you want to be an entrepreneur you want
to stand you will work and work and work
and work and so I think the mistake a
lot of parents are making in my DMs
right now is like oh my son's an
entrepreneur but they're like paying for
the kid to stay at home at 20 years old
laying their bed make them like this is
back to nudging in a direction to find
sometimes that comes also with tough
love it's not just like oh you love
painting with spaghetti amazing no no
there's also like hey if you're gonna
paint with spaghetti you're gonna need
to have figure out how to sell your [__]
you're gonna have some long hard days
like you're gonna have to teach work
ethic one of my favorite stories in the
book Malcolm gladwell's talking about
you know you watch an athlete and they
bounce around from Team to team to team
and then finally it clicks and they're
amazing and he's like these are
multi-million dollar assets and the team
can't figure out how to get them to be
what they're capable of being and he's
like but they try everything the
performance coaches experts they try
different nutrition everything and
eventually in the right circumstances at
the right moment when everything aligns
it's explosive and it says your kid is
saying why can you not give your kid
that same thing understand that just
because they're not thriving in this
environment doesn't mean they're not
capable of thriving it means you have to
find a new environment new circumstance
you also have to be patient and you have
to believe in them and you have to root
for them and eventually it will happen
but you by making them feel guilty they
don't like the job they don't like the
Judgment from the other parents brother
your parents knew you were talented
already they just didn't like the stigma
of a College Dropout because that
luckily some of this shit's changing
yeah I was just talking to a high school
just now and like just even their
questions are like
16 year olds just like girls and boys
asking about investment creativity like
I was like this is nothing like there
was not the whole world's changing the
problem is you got to find that balance
I talk about purple in a with a with the
way that our political system is now
with red and blue find your purple for
your kid who says hey Mom and Dad I'm
gonna make it on my own make sure they
have work ethic because you can't make
it on your own without it so like start
making them uncomfortable or this that
and the other thing but like and not
have delusional conversations Bill
Belichick ended up not being a good
football player yeah he ended up being a
lucky coach in the right circumstance
with an all-time great quarterback or or
he'll prove over the next five years he
is the greatest we'll see Bill we'll see
he said something once where he looks
for coaches and players that played D3
right because they played because they
[__] loved it they loved the mud of
it they love the pain of it they loved
end of it that's what you that's what
you want back to the book what else do
people need to know about it I make a
big distinction between having kids and
being a parent
a lot of people have kids right having
kids is something biological and
something legal you sign the adoption
papers but deciding to be a parent and
to make it a central part of who you are
and how you measure the success of your
life right like at the end of your life
are you going to care about how much
money you made are you going to care
about the awards you want what your
reputation no shot you're gonna look
around you and go why don't I see my
kids very often why don't we have a good
relationship why are we doing why are we
doing Thanksgiving alone or why is it a
chore to get them to come home or to go
to them right you got to think about in
the distant future the way you're going
to measure your life is how crowded your
table is 100
and I've always you know I had a saying
I used to say a lot I was like I'm
playing to see how many people show up
to my funeral and the first people that
need to show up are my kids you know
what I mean and so like it's a it's a
tremendous point and ideally there
around you before you die right well of
course to your point like I've got some
close relatives who are nicer to their
parents
Tombstone than they were to them when
they were around and I see it a lot
Russian culture had a lot of these
negative relationships the Soviet Union
wasn't the greatest box to play in so I
have a lot of empathy for my family
history but boy is it right in my face
yeah and and so if that's what's gonna
matter in the future
think about what you're valuing today
and is that in alignment right you think
about the arguments you have with your
kids about are they keeping their
clothes clean what is there like you're
you're sweating things I mean nothing
that are that are telegraphing to them
what your priorities are when your
ultimate priorities yeah let's talk
about telegraphing what about
affirmation do you touch on the dangers
of creating affirmation around silly
things like looks or athletic ability or
straight A's yeah do you touch on it the
Stokes make this big distinction is it
in your control or not in your control
and when you think about what you
compliment your kids on what you
encourage them for what you celebrate is
it stuff that's up to them or not up to
them right if you go you're so handsome
you're complimenting something that's
not really up to them and if they don't
feel handsome then they're not going to
feel valuable but if you what about them
getting believing that but then going
through life and becoming vulnerable to
what they consider themselves great for
so I think about the other side which is
if like you're getting reinforced that
you're handsome or beautiful your whole
life are you then prone in your late 30s
early 40s to start having a real issue
as your body and your life changes and
are you the ones like that's a really
tough thing to have your validation
framed on because
father time is undefeated yeah no if
what's beautiful The Stokes would say is
is your kid making beautiful choices who
they are about what they value but who
they have around them yeah so so
complimenting and encouraging them and
noticing the things that are up to them
that they're putting in the work on
that's fantastic right are they getting
better did they try their best did you
see them really putting themselves out
there that's different than internet did
they win did they get the award whatever
I try to focus on things that aren't in
my kids control and that's what I
celebrate about them but I also say to
them you know as Mr Rogers did I love
you because you're you right you make
the world better because you're you like
who you inherently are is special and
wonderful and that's that's what makes
you crazy what about on the flip side do
you touch on in a world of all this
awesomeness when they [__] up yeah do
you talk about
Candor with kids or do you does the book
touch on holding your children
accountable in not creating a delusional
framework that they're the best and they
can do everything yeah look we all make
mistakes and I think that's something we
need to do better as parents right like
when you lose your temper or when you're
distracted or when you break your word
how quick are you to go you know what I
screwed up that's on me that doesn't
mean I suck right that means I was
sucked for a hundredth of a second yeah
or it's a micro
stink instead of suck and then you're
giving your kids permission to see
themselves as distinct from the bad
decision they made the thing they got
arrested for the thing they failed math
class for you made a bad decision in
that circumstance that's in the past so
are you going to make better decisions
now are going to be closer to who I know
you're capable of being are you gonna
make amends with the people you hurt yes
are you gonna get back on track back in
the groove of it because I know that you
can and that's what I love about you
you touch on something I found
fascinating when two parents who are
listening right now we're not fully
aligned and they play a ping-pong of
pulling from too far of an opposite
direction instead of one of them seeing
it and coming to the middle
yeah I think you know there's this uh
thing where you've got to back your
spouse right but what if your spouse is
the one who's having the right day who's
frustrated and I don't think you do your
kids any favor by gaslighting them and
going no mom's being totally reasonable
here when you know you know like you can
pull your kid aside and go look I think
she's frustrated in this instance or
she's mad about that other thing which
is why this is happening this is why
this is such a big deal do you think
parents have an opportunity to talk more
grown up with kids what's your hot take
on that I do I do and that's what I do
too I try to and it's a balance but I
try to apologize I try to explain what's
going on I try to explain where my
weaknesses are where my flaws are
because I want to show that they're
they're going to see some of themselves
in me of course they're also going to
come to understand what it means to be
an adult through me what about when your
kid just has the DNA of like a bad uncle
and it like had nothing to do with your
accountability like because Uncle Johnny
was and they took their DNA like what
about really molding some of the
I'll tell you where I get triggered even
the energy I just had the last two
seconds
I just don't like being mean to people
for no reason sure and of course that
comes from insecurity and you can talk
it through but what about like
understanding that actions have
ramifications and things of that nature
yeah life has consequences because when
I asked you in earlier you kind of went
to like hey which is right hey look at
yourself first before you tell your kids
everything what about if like I mean I'm
just thinking about a lot of youngsters
that I know right now given my
children's age and just relatives and
friends and like
some people just come out of the womb
different sure DNA is real yes yeah I
don't I don't I don't think biological I
don't think biology is Destiny in this
of course it's not that that there's
anyone that's hopeless or helpless I
mean you just talked about the thing I
most believe in you could have had the
toughest 34 years of your life had the
outside world judge you for your race
gender sexual preference you could have
a human being grown up at 11 years old
do something you could have incredibly
challenging life circumstances lose
parents both my parents lost a parent
before they were 16. like life is
complicated and yet to your point at 34
you could just go therapy listening to
different stuff reading different stuff
surrounding yourself with different
people people dig themselves out of
these Depots all the time so to your
point when you're zero years old you
definitely aren't destined to have an
issue I'm asking for the parents that
are listening right now which I have a
lot of this audience who are uh very
risk adverse and they have an
entrepreneurial 11 year old or both
parents just happen to be the sweetest
kind of simple and their kids are
bullying the [__] out of people because
they just like what do you do when
you're like whoa neither one of us here
like this kid how what are your thoughts
on that okay
extroverted parents and then you've got
an introverted kids right yeah I love
that shot I I love that too that's what
makes life yes like if everyone was just
like everyone else and so you gotta you
gotta understand who they are and you
gotta understand what makes them great
and your job I heard this great
distinction are you a carpenter or are
you a gardener right A gardener prunes
pulls weeds right but they don't they
can't build it into what they want it to
be so you got to find out who they are
what their Destiny is as that seed and
then you've got to help it succeed but
also get rid of this get rid of the
stuff that shouldn't be there too you
know what I mean of course I do I mean
look people ask me all the time they're
like do you want your kids to be
entrepreneurs I'm like only if they want
to be like I want them to be an
entrepreneur because they didn't want it
as a matter of fact I'm petrified they
would ever consider it because I was one
yeah I want them to like their thing the
way I love my thing even if it was like
I wouldn't want to be a Patriots fan but
like like but like like it's just so
obvious to me that like forcing someone
to be what you want them to be is like
the worst for an employee or a friend
for a child it's that's bad to do it for
your siblings or your buddy yeah like
forcing round holes into square pegs
especially out of your own insecurities
is the big flaw of modern parenting and
historical parenting and it's it's not
gonna work they're going to resent you
for it it's gonna never work later even
if they said even if they look what's
the best case scenario you created Tiger
Woods right and then he hates you for
making him Tiger Woods right it's not
going to be worth and by the way for
Tiger Woods is on such a like like do
you know any doctors lawyers and
Engineers actively are that right now
actively right this second that tens of
thousands of people over the next five
years will listen to this exact podcast
and this exact moment they're 39 years
old making a ton of money it all looks
good and they are pissed like all the
way through because they never tried to
be an Olympian or they didn't get to
become a chef or they never tried to be
an Archer well and this is why I
actually do think it's important that
you're just proud of your kids for who
they are right that that coming out of
the womb you're proud of them you love
them you think they have worth so they
don't think that they have to do X Y or
Z to make you love them to make them
proud of you that they don't have to
follow in your footsteps because that's
the only way to perceive your good
graces or or get time with you by by
yeah yes it's true there's too much
participation trophies maybe too much
self-esteem nonsense but if you let your
if you support and love your kids
unconditionally and let them know that
they have worth they'll follow their own
and by the way self-esteem needs to be
like really contextualized I think what
you and I are talking about is actual
self-esteem be instead of manipulated
self-esteem the only way you'll get
self-esteem is if you know you're
actually good at something yeah like
like so find like I really do think
every do I think every person is born
and can be phenomenal at something I'm
not sure but boy do I believe out of the
8 billion people on Earth walking around
the far majority never found the thing
that they were most capable of meaning
like like you know what I mean like I
don't think everyone could be an
all-world Hall of Fame X but I'm sure
right now someone's an accountant who
could have been one of the really
significantly top five percent uh auto
mechanics
like we're just not explore it you know
you talk about it and I talk about a ton
of taste things we're creating more
Frameworks to letting kids taste things
and the funniest part is if you just
watch your kid you don't even have to do
this work everyone ironically your kids
will show you somewhere between eight
and fifteen they're gonna start
gravitating towards interests they're
showing you in their face that they
think carpentry is amazing or they want
to be a lawyer like all you have to do
is be open to what they're telling you
and by the way you said something
powerful when you were just talking
around I was like right every parent
loves your kid to death at six months
they haven't done [__] yet except poop
right like but you [__] love them
somewhere along the way
you start creating expectations and it's
conditional of course and all based on
your own [__] [__] insecurities
worrying about what your neighbors think
if your kids go into [__] Ivy League
school or how many goals they scored in
[__] lacrosse you [__] no and
they're gonna it's not going to work
ever it's not gonna work and look they
might become a powerful lawyer great
whatever but if if it doesn't mean
something to them it will feel empty and
meaningless and they'll find some way as
Tiger Woods ultimately did to act out to
undermine it because they weren't doing
it for them
boy do I believe let's wrap us up what
else uh what else should we touch on the
last couple minutes here anything we
didn't touch on naturally in our flow I
have a good question man we always just
talk you know like I always feel
s love this because it's always so
different because I really enjoy talking
to you because I do think
we share a lot of views and we have
different tweaks and turns on it but
like the you know what I love about you
and what I loved about this conversation
I hope everybody understood this was a
massive conversation about love
such good intent this is so powerful the
the last thing you know you talk about
you're gonna die yes you need to realize
the shortness of light that doesn't just
apply to you that applies to the people
you love also right no one's here
forever we don't know how long we have
with them they have with us the other
thing about kids is
growing up is a process of diary you'll
never be a two-year-old again a three
right cool and so you've gotta it can
you can be so busy as a parent you're
rushing through things like bedtime
you're like it's got to take first
window to this window and you're rushing
to what answer [__] email to catch
you know to catch something Ted lasso
yeah to stream which by the way I know
you need parents like we all need
escapism but to your point I'm already
in it like you're not there's no time
machines yeah for everybody's got a 15
year old right now just think for one
second how much should you pay for them
to be six again for a lot of people they
might say nah [__] I'm happy but like
for a lot of us it's like [__] those are
special times I can tell you right now
all you all you girl dads like [__]
starts happening at 12 13 14 15 16
friends become their world they start
becoming a woman and Mom become like all
of a sudden that little six-year-old
that wanted to cuddle with you all the
time like you won't see them for a
decade according to parents that are
ahead of you that blows you're rushing
through the thing you're going to miss
more than anything 100 100
[__] percent
I hope this brought some value to
everybody please go out is the book out
yeah come down tomorrow book is out by
the time you're listening to this you
know how to find them it's all on Amazon
just search or or the other platforms
the daily dad Ryan holiday always a
pleasure thanks love you bro
[Music]
thank you